>>Teacher: Good morning,
students and staff,
we're ready for another
great day of learning at--
>>Narrator: Like most urban
districts, Louisville,
Kentucky's schools have faced
myriad challenges, from high numbers
of children on free
and reduced lunch,
to escalating fights
and rising suspensions.
>>Alicia: There were a
lot of factors that played
into the scores being low.
There was not a caring, learning
environment that allowed teachers
to teach and students to learn.
>>Paul: We had a whole lot of
bullying going on around here,
kids getting scared
to come to school,
people be hitting people,
more violent stuff.
>>Teacher: Okay, we've been
discussing bullying all week long.
>>Narrator: In two thousand eight, a
comprehensive initiative called CARE
for Kids was adopted
by dozens of elementary
and middle schools
in Jefferson County.
It featured a laser beam focus
on social emotional skills,
spearheaded by Superintendent
Shelly Berman.
>>Sheldon: There's a pretty complex
puzzle that we have to put together
to have a successful school,
but a foundational element
of that puzzle is the culture
and climate of that school.
And when students feel safe...
>>Alicia: Hello, sweet girl,
you have a good day, okay?
>>Sheldon: When they feel that that
culture and climate supports them,
when they feel cared about, not
only by the adults in the school,
but by other students in the
school, they can do their best.
>>Teacher: And that does sound good,
"My teacher teaches terrifically."
I like that alliteration too.
>>Teacher: Let's talk about what
respectful group work in science,
what does it look like, what does
it sound like and what does it feel
like when we do those things?
>>Narrator: In every classroom,
teachers help students decide
on detailed class norms for behavior.
>>Teacher: This is the
list I got from you.
We're happy, we're proud,
and what does it sound like?
>>Level one.
>>Very good job.
>>Teacher: We're working
together, Germaine.
>>Help them if they need help.
>>Help them if they need home.
>>Alicia: Less instructional
time is lost
because we're teaching the skills
up front and so that when it is time
for academics, we're learning
and we're not stopping
at various times to
address conflicts.
And it's teaching the students how
to have ownership and have voice.
>>Keirsi: I think level zero
in the hallway is a good rule,
because if we were talking and
it's this little thing on the top,
and echoes come out of it.
And classes might be up
there learning something
and we can disturb them easily.
>>Teacher: Look at the name on
your piece of paper and think
of something nice to
say about that person.
>>Good morning, Storm.
>>Good morning, Deirdre.
>>I like your humor.
>>Sheldon: It isn't touchy feely
stuff, it's core social skills
that gives students the experience
and the knowledge and talent
to work effectively with others.
>>Thanks for always being nice.
>>Sheldon: This is serious work.
It's serious work to
create a sense of community.
>>Teacher: How did it feel to say
something nice about someone else?
>>Student: It felt good, because I
actually gotta say something positive
about somebody.
>>Student: Yours was a
fight, right, fighting?
You all had a fight?
>>Physical.
>>Yeah, physical.
>>Sheldon: Developmental
discipline is looking
for appropriate consequences.
For example, a student
pushes another student,
or takes something away
from another student.
You might say, "Well, let's
give that student a detention
so they have to stay after school."
But that isn't an appropriate
consequence,
that isn't a direct consequence.
A student doesn't necessarily
learn anything from that.
The appropriate consequence
may be to write an apology
or to directly apologize
to that student,
and it's also teaching them
conflict resolution skills.
>>Student: Do you think you
can show better judgment
than what you did in the gym?
>>Teacher: Now look, look
what you've got here.
You already got a good
start right there.
>>Bill: We reduced our placements
of in school suspensions in half.
We have increased our
attendance, our pupil attendance,
every single pupil month as
compared to the previous year,
so created an environment, I think,
of less problems in the classroom
and in the school in
terms of behavior,
and a sense of students
wanting to be at school.
>>Alicia: Our academic index overall,
reading, math, every content area,
we were at a fifty-three.
We're now at an eighty-two and our
math score is up to a ninety-four.
>>Joanna: Tell Jasmine what
you think is special about her.
>>I like when you share with me.
>>Thank you-- Carolyn.
>>Joanna: The whole morning meeting
not only sets a really good tone
for the students, but
it sets a tone for me.
>>Thanks for filling my bucket.
>>Joanna: How did they fill
your bucket today, Jasmine?
>>Because they was real nice to me.
>>Joanna: They're excited,
they want to be here.
I've had parents say, "My
daughter's sick today,
but she cried 'cause she really
wanted to come to school.
You know, what are you all doing?"
>>Richard: Now stay in
line, don't run, don't run.
>>I like this program and I see
this program that's been implemented
and it works, because I was
here and I seen it for myself.
>>See you tomorrow, okay, buddy?
>>At the end of the day, those
kids getting on those buses,
with a smile on their
face, my job is done.
I can safely go home
and say, "You know what,
when they came this
morning, they had smiles
and when they left they had smiles."
Our job is done, because of CARE.
>>Your mom's outside, your
mom's right there Madison.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.